um
let's let can we talk about real estate
and debt and the relationship with that
um let's start with debt because i
remember
you called into this was probably three
or four months ago you called into the
bet david podcast and
this was right well actually this was
right after the election so
you know we were dealing with some of
the uh ramifications
of all that and you said i'm gonna quote
you here uh robert you said
you don't need money because you can go
to the bank and borrow it you also said
you have a billion dollars
in debt and you borrow money to buy real
estate
put yourself in the shoes of the average
american what should their relationship
with that look like they should you know
another friend of mine i forgot his name
now but he always says live debt free
yeah we know the man you're talking
about dave ramsey
he's a good friend of mine he's accurate
if you have no financial education
live debt-free but if you want to do
what a real capitalist does which is use
debt and pay no taxes
because that's what happened in 1971 the
us dollar became debt
and it was only offset via taxes
otherwise the only way debt can be paid
off
is by the american taxpayer paying taxes
so i started studying and so in 1973 i
took my first real estate course
and i never stopped that's why i have
tremendous respect for what patrick
david and valuetainment is doing
is because you guys are teaching people
from the real world of money
now i'm not saying buy real estate or
stocks or bonds or mutual funds
i'm saying please get educated and
listen to real teachers
you know i would never tell you to live
debt-free
i would never tell you to invest in a
mutual fund
you know how manipulated those things
are
you know i don't trust etfs and bonds
are the worst investment possible today
but that's what everybody's getting into
so we're going to have
what the marine corps says it's an f
word there's going to be
a big one coming up soon and that's why
i wrote the book
who stole my pension because all the bad
assets are dumped in pension funds by
wall street
you know that i know that but the
average guy doesn't
they go to school they get a job and
they get a 401k
i mean for most people that's the best
thing they can do
if they don't want to invest in their
financial education
that's my advice well well said
thank you for watching this short clip
if you want to see the full episode
check it out right here and if you have
not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here
you